Two legacy
media giants are in
early talks to combine forces.
Sources say that Warner Brothers
Discovery, UW BD, our parent company,
is reporting
to looking into a merger with Paramount.
They're not the same size,
but both are double
digit billion dollar brands
with big portfolios of movies
and TV shows and streaming networks.
Investors have not welcomed
the move, at least on one tide.
Warner Brothers Discovery is down 2%.
Paramount Global is up 2%.
Vivian Schiller is the former CEO of NBA.
All is with me now.
Vivian, when I see that sort of number,
WPP down to the other side, up to
it usually means
somebody should be doing this
and somebody shouldn't.
What do you take from it?
Well, look,
first of all, it's important to say
that this deal is highly speculative.
We know that there was a conversation.
I suspect
we know that this conversation
happened between, by the way,
which was between
David Zaslav,
the CEO of Warner Brothers
Discovery
and Paramount Global CEO Bob Bakish.
We know this happened
because obviously
they wanted us to know this.
This happened to be to be clear.
There are issues with it.
There's tremendous debt.
There's paramount is mostly the legacy
company.
There's issues around
the terms of Discovery's last merger.
There's antitrust issues,
and then there's the market, as you say.
But you know what?
There's also a lot of upside here.
All right.
I need to correct one thing,
a technical a technical glitch.
Actually, both are down
about just not exactly down
two and a half percent.
The gremlins are in the system,
but but the call. So I apologize.
But, Vivien, the core question here is WB
already has $40 billion worth of debt
and there are cutbacks and movements
and all within the WB deal.
How on earth would the company
go forward with such a purchase
and or even any form of merger
with Paramount
which has its own basket of debt
group.
But there's also a lot of value
to extract
from the merger of these two companies.
There are first of all, there's
upside value.
So the incredible sports assets
that Discovery
have now,
you have CBS broadcast
as an outlet for that.
There is obviously at CNN
the which
we are broadcasting on right now
and CBS News,
that's obviously an option
for efficiencies,
not a word that journalists like to hear,
but it has to be said.
But also,
there's the ability for
the newly merged company
to have greater leverage
in terms of their carriage deal.
If you take all of Warner
Brothers and Discovery's
tremendous cable assets
and you add to that a Nickelodeon comedy
Central, Showtime,
that's a lot more leverage
to extract value.
Now, Vivian,
one of the crucial things
in all of these maneuvers
is that famous phrase,
putting the company in play.
Now that these talks have happened,
everybody knows
essentially Paramount is in play
and others may come out of the woodwork
to have a run at it, too.
WPT, of course, is somewhat hampered
by the various tax rules.
That means it can't go forward fully
until sort of mid
spring to mid-next year.
But do you agree
Paramount is now in play?
Oh, without a doubt.
And if you're Comcast's NBCU, of course
you're looking at it,
as are many other entities.
There is look paramount,
especially in the in this era
when it's all about
the streaming behemoths,
Netflix and Disney.
Plus Paramount has,
you know,
not as big an asset,
but a valuable asset in Paramount Plus.
You combine that with
Discovery, Time Warner's Warner Max
or other assets from obviously from from
from Comcast.
And that's a lot more leverage.
It's is
these are some very attractive
properties. Right. But
but and this is
I always think this is the cool part
when you see
legacy is getting together,
whether it's airlines or media.
But is this two drunk men
trying to hold each other up?
Well, I wasn't in the room,
so I can't say.
But, look, you know,
like you
know as well as I do,
legacy media is declining
and these are largely legacy
media outlets,
but they have incredible value
in their intellectual property.
These shows, these channels
that are still beloved.
So maybe,
you know,
huddle them together
for warmth is exactly
what's necessary here.
The assets
I'm just looking at the assets now.
I mean,
they are up salute lutely formidable
especially.
I mean
I mean, never mind the broadcast assets.
Paramount Pictures,
along with Warner Brothers
and just on the movie side,
simply formidable.
Yeah.
Tom Cruise, still a big star.
He's a Paramount guy
here.
I watched that movie
flying across the Atlantic last night.
I watched the latest Mission Impossible.
It was so long part one.
We got across the Atlantic
and I still didn't manage to finish it.
Good to see you.
I'm grateful for your time.
Thank you. Thank you.